good morning
everybody
morning all
right before we begin can we rise for
please all right being 10:03 I'm going
to open up the public hearing on house
Bill 1062 relative to the use of Special
cover plates um I'll start off by saying
anybody who would wishes to put their
position down one way or the other
without speaking we have our blue sheets
up front if you do wish to speak there
are pink cards fill them out and hand
them down please uh chair recognizes the
prime sponsor of 1062 representative Pro
good
morning good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee I hope this is
an easy one for you it deals with our
cover plates the State Rep
plates um I actually brought this bill
forward a few years back and I was told
then by the director that we didn't need
it it was already the way that you could
do it and what I'm looking to do is put
my State Rep plate on the front my
regular plate stays on the back and um
he said I could do it I asked him for a
letter he never gave me one and then
shortly after I had a discussion with a
State Trooper on the side of the highway
about that deal and he said no I went to
Division of Motor Vehicles they said
nope you can't do that so I would really
like to be able to swap
them um it's not like I'm hiding
anything if you uh run either one of
those plates they come back to me and my
car so
um
for me I just really want that plate on
so I can get into the garage on session
days and you know every once in a while
I might do something stupid and I don't
need to let everybody know who I am and
such and see me on Facebook
and what have
you all right thank you and I'm happy to
take questions okay great uh any
questions from the
committee seeing n oh hold on represent
Fox thank you Mr chairman so just so I
understand the reason you want this is
only for the purpose of getting in and
out of the
garage what would you have your
legislative plate on the front is that's
correct your regular plate on the back I
prefer to have my legislative plate on
the front so if I need it from something
else maybe parking around you know
running in to the state house to pick up
a bill or something it identifies that
I'm a State Rep and
I just prefer to have that in the front
and my regular plate in the back I have
a nice
plate uh so I like to show it off don't
want to hide it for two
years thank you any further
C thank you for taking a question would
there be any preferences to which one
goes on the front and which on the back
would would you see any variation I I
believe people would probably do a
variation and I want to leave that open
to the person with the plates so I know
I'm going to put mine in my rep plate in
the front and leave my regular plate in
the back I'm not sure what other people
would like to do but I
think they come back to us so whatever
combination I I think is up to
them any other
questions wow represent of rumo who
thank you thank you for taking my
question I'm just wondering if you got
any feedback if any sort of
administrative confusion or how this
would work in terms of so you did run
into office and were parked and got a
ticket for some reason being not in a
designated spot you know which plate
they're going to run or if it's through
you know through the computer system
through their app I mean so as far as I
know uh they both are in the computer
system they both come back to me and by
law I have to have my regular plates
either on the vehicle or in the
vehicle so that if there ever is a
question they can go right back to my
regular
plate yeah okay thank you anybody
representative y thank you Mr Speaker um
Mr
Speaker got a promotion Mr chairman I'm
sorry can um can I I I don't know if
this is for the representative or or
this is for you but when you uh when you
go into the parking lot legislative
parking lot and there's the security
guard out there is he checking your
plate or is he looking to see if you
have that green sticker on your
windshield I thought that's what the
sticker was for but they also do
recognize the plates I mean we we're the
only ones that get them uh that's the
best I can answer your question we'd
have to talk with them personally thank
you because to be honest with you uh I
have never put a decal on my vehicle I
rely on the plates
so anybody else from the committee all
right seeing that thank you very
Hill would there be any reason to have
that um on the front of your plate for
things like uh the um fast pass lane or
something like that could be yeah
because that's what they look at when we
go through if you don't have an easy
pass because I don't think every member
has an Easy Pass anymore so would would
you be amendable to an amendment that
required um to work it the way you
currently would like to to have the sure
I just try to in be all inclusive you
know Kindler gentler and all that and uh
so whatever you people
committee decides is fine as long as I
can have my plate on the front I'll be
happy thank
you anybody else um I had always thank
you very much no more questions I was
always under the impression that you
could do what you're proposing to do now
also I don't have anybody from safety or
DMV signed up with a with Clarity on
this but if you'd like to offer it it'd
be
great thanks
okay I get Kathleen yeah my last name is
Diamond it's d ym n t okay and I am the
um supervisor of the registration Bureau
at the DMV thank you so just want to let
you know you were speaking about having
um if it runs through our system that
your legisl plates show up they don't
right now we currently maintain all your
registrations and information in the
database on a spreadsheet so we don't
have it built in if a police officer
were to pull you over they wouldn't
plate at one time they were actually
embossing the registration and filling
all the information on the Reg
registrations are they but since Co I
don't think they're doing that anymore
are they we are not we just have a form
and it's up to you to put it in your
vehicle where you want whatever vehicle
you want it into so we don't we've never
had it in our system we've always
maintained a
spreadsheet
okay what about the
tolls what what if if somebody's running
to me it doesn't matter you can either
run one cover plate on the front or two
what if the tolls how does the tolls
recognize that do you know I know it's
not your department um honestly I don't
works fair enough any other
questions just an observation we have
available the uh the toll transponders
in the orange container the yeah but not
everybody's got a transponder if you
were to go through the tolls and they
had a question they would reach out to
us and we'd look on our spreadsheet to
see who had that house plate and who it
belongs to okay uh again I know called
you um uh without notice U does the
department have an opinion either way we
don't have an opinion either way thank
you very much you're welcome any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much but nobody else signed up I'm going
to close the public hearing on House
Bill
okay being 10:20 I'm going to open up
the public hearing on House Bill
1083 relative to Vehicles held in joint
tency with rights of
survivorship uh I won't go through my
normal disclosures because there's
nobody here in the room it appears to to
speak to it um chair recognizes the
prime sponsor of the bill representative
Hill good morning Mr chairman thank you
um for the record I am representative
Greg Hill I represent Northfield um
which is marrat 2
I'm here um actually at the request of a
constituent from Northfield uh who was a
Survivor um and had veterans plates um
that meant a great deal to she and her
husband
um at the death of the
spouse
um she was told that she could continue
the registration I think for eight 18
months or one additional time and then
she was required to um give up the
plates and um re-register or retitled
the the vehicle um we
inquired um if there was a if that was
an optional um item for that she
wouldn't have to if she was keeping
everything the same and uh and we were
told no um there the DMV is not in the
business of of titling vehicles to dead
people so um the question is why uh what
what difference would it make if this
was uh done in in terms of a right of
survivorship anyway it was registered
that way with both she and her husband
on there
um why wouldn't it be possible for her
to just keep uh the the titling the same
and not have to retitle the vehicle and
um and just uh change the inspection
date to her birthday and have everything
move along as it as it would um the only
requirement would be upon sale or
trading in the vehicle or something of
those nature she would uh she would
provide um the death certificate
and uh and that seemed like it would
solve every issue and it wouldn't mean
that someone would have to go to the
extra step um
needlessly I have a feeling since I
filed this i' I've had a new an well at
least uh a full handful of people say
yeah the same thing happened to me um or
to my mother-in-law or my something um
so I think it's more common than than we
may think um but I have no no way of
knowing um it just seemed that this
would be a good way to get the answer to
the question why why we have to make
someone um do an extra step when there
really is no benefit to it and with that
I'll end my
testimony thank you sir any questions
from the
committee wow they're letting you off
easy thank you sir been
brilliant uh next up chair next up chair
recognizes Jennifer
correct and without taking a position on
the
bill good morning chairman and members
of the committee my name is Jennifer o
I'm the title bureau administrator with
the Division of Motor Vehicles I have
been with the division Motor Vehicles
for 20 years focusing mainly on the
vehicle side of the division which would
be both registration en title with me I
have Kathleen Diamond again the
assistant supervisor of
registrations um we wanted to just kind
of fill in some of the gaps and let you
guys understand why uh we do have a
deceased individual removed from a title
in a registration so an individual who
is no longer with us being listed on a
registration or a title does open up for
certain areas of fraud uh for other
people to be able to put their names on
on registrations and titles and maintain
um ownership of vehicle for an
individual that is no longer with us
does open up for uh for some areas of
fraud in addition to that with the
veterans plates it's not us that sets a
standard for the veterans plate it's
actually the um Veterans Affairs that
sets the guidelines for who's qualified
to have um certain veterans plates on
their vehicles so in this case if you
are are if you have a disabled veteran
plate on your vehicle and um you are
deceased then nobody else can carry that
on because they're not the individual
that has the uh disability that is uh
related to
service I'm not as where I'll end that
right thank you any questions from the
committee representative sellers thank
you Mr chair so you're saying open is up
to fraud can you explain how yes great
great question thank you for that so an
individual who is no longer with us uh
cannot sign for ownership and um the
surviving spouse can only remove their
name can't actually add their name
doesn't have the legal authority to add
a deceased individual's name so then
being able to continue registrations is
going to show proof of ownership it also
shows who is with us and who is not uh
walking disability privileges are also
related to documents that are coming out
of our system um so in order for us to
monitor that we also go by the documents
that are in there and current and active
status any other questions represent
C thank you for taking my question um
the question I have is if this were
enacted uh what might you see as being a
problem if the surviving spouse then
remarried thank you for your question I
think as it relates to registrations I'm
going to understand am I understanding
your question that it relates directly
to
registrations well and or the title and
or the title so um from the title aspect
it would have no bearing if the
individual uh remarries there's no
privileges associated with that if the
surviving spouse were to want to sign
ownership over partial ownership over to
their new partner then um just a proper
assignment on the back with a copy of
the death certificate would take
place as for registration I'll turn it
over to you thank you so for
registration in order to register the
vehicle the title in the registration
must match so if they were to sign over
to their new spouse we would have to um
adjust the registration to reflect that
change and if I may want add a followup
to that many registrations do not speak
to who the owner is so if if I were to
have a special number plate say a
four-digit passenger plate my surviving
spouse would be entitled to that they
would be the first person entitled to
that so they would for No Charge um
complete a transfer of ownership on a
title which is just the title itself and
a copy of the death certificate which
they can do strictly right at their town
clerk's office and then they would be
able to inherit that plate they would
also be able to add additional family
members onto that plate if they were
adding it on to the title if you adding
an additional family member um onto the
title there is a charge to retitle it uh
however those plates they would be
allowed to maintain it's just certain
veteran statuses that they would not be
able
to representative
Jones Thank you Mr
chairman uh and thank you for answering
my questions
um I thought the bill was a nice
sentimental Bill uh and you've shown us
the obstacles but is there a different
way is there route we can go to make
this happen that doesn't upset the whole
apple
cart thank you for your question you
bring up a very good point this is you
know talking about sentimental wanting
to maintain your status uh being proud
of your spouse who is a veteran and
serve for our country completely
understand that I think that further
discussion would need to take place
where we could kind of look at what laws
and rules this would impact and if there
are other agencies that would have a
stake in this I think that that would be
worth it thank you so
much representative sellers thank you Mr
chair uh I just want to bring up we do
have a house bill 1354 where we will be
looking at which has to deal with
veterans plates and survivors of
veterans basally almost the same idea so
I just want to bring up that fact and um
I on this bill here though I'm thinking
here is usually when someone there
someone has the Survivor a deceased
person um yeah it's you know again
they're going through a lot of different
things at that time is there a way that
we could actually say look we we can
give you the new title without cost or
trying to make their life easier somehow
is that absolutely thank you for your
question and you bring up a lot of great
points our current statutes allow for
our surviving spouse to take up to 13
months at no charge to come in and
retitle their vehicles so it's not
something that's Ed while they're
dealing with all of the other stuff that
comes along with losing a loved one in
addition to that um there are
permissions that allow for registration
to be maintained for one year or up to
up to one year or date of expiration so
again they wouldn't have to take care of
that so if I were to pass away my
registration expires in September my
husband would have rights to that
vehicle through September of next year
or sorry this year um and wouldn't have
to take care of it until then so that is
something that doesn't have to be high
on the priority list when they're
dealing with everything else that
they're going through and as I said if
it's a surviving spouse just retitling
it in their name there is no charge it's
just a photocopy of the death
certificate and then the title with them
requirement represent coka thank you Mr
chairman uh so just so I understand it
when they retitle it um as far as vanity
plates are concerned they they have
first I guess dibs on the vanity plates
that is correct I do all right on this
instant um because I actually walked
with the woman that brought this bill up
her plate was a disabled veteran plate
and she didn't qualify for that if she
had qualified if she was a disabled
veteran herself she would have been able
to keep that plate um so what we were
able to do for her is get her a veteran
plate with that number and that seemed
to make her happy because it was very
sentimental that number to her okay yeah
that's what I was just want to make sure
I understood it correctly thank you
you're welcome any further questions
from the
committee I only have one yeah you
stated that it was the State Department
of Veterans Affairs that basically
dictates how long a surviving spouse can
maintain that plate um is that in
statute the Veterans Affairs determines
who has eligibility and qualifies for
those plates um the maintaining any
plate for one year or up until um Reg
ation is determined by the Division of
Motor Vehicles and those are in statute
and Rule and we can get those over to
you if that would be
helpful thank you any other
questions seeing none uh I have nobody
else signed up to speak on this I'm
going to close the public hearing on
House Bill
1083 thank you for your time thank you
thank you um few minutes actually next
one's at
11:22
be at 10:40 I'll open up the public
hearing on House Bill
1122 relative to lights on motor
vehicles and the chair recognizes uh
representative Tom
Walsh thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Tom Walsh I'm a represented from the
town of hookit Dunbarton which is
meramac 10 I'm here to introduce House
Bill 1122 FN relative to lights on motor
vehicles uh I I uh met with the
Department of Motor Vehicles and
department of safety Last Summer uh they
had some concerns about some of the
lighting on vehicles in the state um
among them are the color of the lights
and when lights are being used by your
ride share companies Uber being Blue by
the way uh and some of the aftermarket
lights headlights some of these things
have Halos um so we have a lot of
aftermarket products that are being used
and then they've got some legitimate
concerns also uh you might notice a lot
of people using on their trucks these
new LED light bues which are very very
bright so after a long meeting with them
and a follow-up conversation I agreed
with everything they said they've got
some legitimate concerns so I put the
bill in for them so I will defer to the
details and specifications to the
Department of Safety uh and thank you
very much and that's how you do it
representative
C thank you so much representative for
your testimony any
stclair would this would this uh also
apply to motorcycles that like to ride
around with the lights on the bottom of
their motorcycles that project green red
blue blue
yellow so it's not a headlight it's the
you know you know what I'm talking about
the lights that thank you I didn't see
anything about motorcycles specifically
in here but I know the colored lamps are
um a topic so I'll have to look into
that deeper or the question might be
better serve to the Department of
Safety I do know we did pass a a year or
two ago allowing for three lights on the
front of a motorcycle versus the two
four some of these aftermarket lights uh
but that didn't come up in the
conversation that we had over the summer
follow up follow up thank
you when I have these vehicles behind me
I'm thinking a
motorcycle you see the headlights but
you also see these other lights because
they're bright they're low to the ground
so they do catch your attention and
that's what I'm talking about so you
understand you understand what I'm
talking about not just headlights okay
thank you don't see that as a
problem okay thank you I don't see them
offer any other questions representative
V thank you uh just a quick one uh does
the prohibition on light bars affect
work Vehicles such as private plow
trucks that might need to use a light on
text I believe it does it's it does not
spell out that it's it's it's
recreational vehicles
only I'm looking at actually line 10 on
page two uh or might be actually
starting on page eight um it's General
it's not specific to either residential
commercial any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank
you chair now like to recog izes Dan
Bennett who's asking for three minutes
bill uh thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee uh good morning and I will
be brief uh Dan Bennett Hampshire Auto
Dealers Association we're our trade
Association representing the motor
vehicle industry um so I'm here today uh
on behalf of our inspection stations um
to give you a little bit of Industry
perspective Ive on chairman Walsh's bill
which as mentioned NH does support um
the industry perspective is that these
couple changes to the inspection law are
common sense uh problem was identified
by DMV um and the fix was suggested and
we think it's a good one um to
representative St Clair's question uh
yeah importantly section two does treat
motorcycles equitably it affects cars
and motorcycles as far as lamp covering
um and we did touch auxiliary lamping
two sessions ago allowing for four uh
four forward-facing um auxiliary lamps
the LED bar um to represent V's question
is an interesting one um we do support
it um because it's not requiring capping
in a lot of auxiliary lamping sometimes
you see capping required uh this one
makes it a capping can sometimes come at
a cost so this just uh says that they
can't be illuminated when on way um
there is I guess a bit of a technical
question there because my driveway if
open to the public can actually be
considered a public way like a retail
veh car dealer's lot is considered a
public way because the public can access
it but it comes to a Law Enforcement
issue where LED light bars are most
popular is in plow trucks um on on roofs
uh on plow accessory kits um I'm highly
um doubt that law enforcement would
enforce a ticket of a moving motor
violation for illuminated LED lamp bars
when someone was plowing a parking lot
for safety so um although it could be a
tech Calia really in the reality is we
don't see it being enforced um but it's
a it's the whole bill in itself they
they're Common Sense changes um designed
with um really roadway safety in mind
for those that are traveling in on the
roads um you know oddly colored lights
distracting colored lights um lights
that are too bright um have some real
safety issues and this bill addresses
that um and as a result as mentioned we
wholeheartedly support it so um I'll
take any questions if there are
any thank you so much any questions from
the committee representative St Clair
thank you can you explain to me lights
that are too bright could you be more
specific about
that uh I'll do my best representative
thanks for the question so lights are um
are rated and the inspection law
indicates how bright they can be
sometimes it's uh it used to be candle
power uh however that's that's pretty
dated right so I believe they switch to
lumens um which is the light output just
like you would find for uh a a home or
or a fluorescent lamp vehicle headlights
have Lumin ratings too if it's too
bright and it's in an oncoming Lane at
you it can be blinding just like someone
driving by with their um with their
brights on uh so lights have a um a a
cap or a maximum output of lumens that
they're allowed to
have thank
you any other questions from the
you chair would now like to recognize
our Carl hudston from The New Hampshire
Department of Safety who's requesting
bill good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee to my right is
AI supervisor Ken quit um I have some
prepared remarks and uh then we can take
some questions if you'd like if anybody
has any uh the bill addresses equipment
manufacturing within the automotive
industry um protecting the Public's
ability to see while driving at night
and understanding uh the colored lights
on a vehicle as you know uh New
Hampshire law allows for colored lights
on specific uh types of vehicles most
colors such as red blue Amber are
immediately recognized in most instances
as emergency vehicles headlamps and or
halo lights and as as explained before
the Halo or the circular lights around
the headlight uh can be purchased in
Many Colors some of them change um as
they're on I've seen that uh some
manufacturers include this type of
lighting lighting as an option when you
purchase the vehicle white and Amber
lighting are naturally recognized as
color colors that illuminate the front
of a vehicle and
conversely red and blue are are in the
rear when mod when modifications are
made to these colors it can be confusing
to motorist as they may not be able to
recognize the orientation of a vehicle
or the type of vehicle um that they
see um another example would be uh the
ride share as was mentioned
before um they're becoming um
increasingly popular often time these
lights can be observed mounted in the
interior of the windshield uh of the
participating vehicle depending on the
placement and the color of the light uh
driver may be under the misunderstanding
that it's an emergency vehicle uh the
practice of leaving uh that type of
light Illuminator would while driving is
not necessary and obviously can confuse
other motorists uh advances made in the
automotive uh lighting have provided a
variety of auxiliary lighting options to
vehicle owners the customization of both
on and off-road vehicle lighting um has
prevented uh some challenges in the
enforcement and can put the the public
at risk by blinding them and I can
attest to um that uh consequently the
bill seeks to focus on the operation of
the lighting in place of actually
restricting the equipment on the
vehicles themselves and one of the
questions that was
raised um was about uh emergency
lighting on the roof uh New Hampshire uh
has an RSA that talks about emergency
lighting separately from this so it
identifies what type of lighting can be
used for what type of operation
obviously law enforcement is blue fire
department is red and um you know road
work Department of Public Works Are all
uh amber so I know somebody had asked a
question about that so separate law
identifies what colors can be used and
to speak to um the question about um
using this auxiliary
equipment while plowing a a parking lot
or something like that yeah on the law
enforcement side of this no if they're
off the the the main public way and he
is right um a parking lot of a of a
business is technically a public we this
is focused on the actual Road not
somebody's large parking lot so uh just
to make sure that we're not going down
that road um as a law enforcement
um side of this I can't imagine anybody
would
ever pursue
that
so I wouldn't happy to answer any
questions thank you any questions from
the committee representative St
Clair good morning and thank you sure so
I'm going go back to motorcycles okay
one of the question for
motorcyclist riding at night
is is is a high rate of risk that so a
lot of the motorcyclists have now added
if they have um crash bars in the
front or if they have something they can
mount on their front fender they'll put
some lights on those and they're
bright um normally the smart motorcycles
will have a dimmer on there just like
our regular headlights and will dim it
to oncoming traffic but with those
lights
by themselves being added would that
cause an inspection failure or would
they be illegal I mean would there be a
limit if I want to put five on each side
again to Bright brighten up that roadway
ahead of me at night or was on a rainy
night especially would that become
illegal under this
Bill thank you for the question so on
the inspection side of this it wouldn't
um it's not the inspection the motor
vehicle inspection um only f focuses on
required lighting and required equipment
uh if for whatever reason somebody
brought a motorcycle in like that that
had a blue or a red cover on the front
of it obviously that would fail um but
no uh the inspection focuses on on the
required equipment so on line one of the
second page of the bill it talks about
headlight sou shine white when shined
against a white surface all other
forward facing light shall be Amber or
white so
that eliminates any of those other
colors on any lights on the front of the
vehicle um and for inspection purposes
on the motorcycle they they are allowed
to have four forward- facing auxiliary
lights on
that follow up yes please thank you now
I have not seen this enforced in a long
time but the Blue Dot on the tail light
yeah yeah now in the in the bad old days
I call them that would be probable cars
to be pulled over correct because you
had this which was standed back in the
old days that blue dot on the tail light
would that be is that going to be a
problem
again I don't think that it's a problem
now I don't think that's an issue
whatsoever on the tail lights um the
main portion of the tail light is red um
it's actually doesn't turn it blue it
actually turns it purple um it's not
going to be affect the inspection
portion of that no okay thank thank you
very much any other questions from the
committee representative
Jones thank you very much um thank you
for being here uh in many of the smaller
communities that have volunteer fire
departments the firefighters actually
have light sometimes have light bars
right on their own personal vehicles and
I guess the reason is because they're
not responding to a fire from the
station they're responding from their
home to the fire station um what what is
the law with that is I I've seen them in
red I've seen them in
blue thank you for the question um just
you know I I am a call firefighter as
well so I'm quite familiar with this so
again the state has a specific law that
talks about colors for specific
operations yes fire department
operations are listed as red so this
this first of all would not affect us at
all it's actually um it's called
emergency lighting so it does not this
bill does not have any effect on that at
all um the the law that talks about
emergency lighting
says again blue is police red is fire
Amber is for everything
else and
um
this this particular Bill wouldn't
affect that at
so it can still be considered emergency
lighting even if it's on a private
vehicle correct so yes that answers my
question thank you
sure representative foot thank you Mr
chair um on page one lines 22 and 23
every lamp bul or light used in any
headlamp shall be such candle power is
specified by the pro device
so what is too bright ver and is our a
way you to be tested like is
something so um my understanding is that
any any light um that you
purchase you can find the actual lumens
that it puts out if you care to
um the state does have a standard I
don't know it off the top of my head
okay so is there is there sorry Mr chair
follow follow up so is there a way if
someone would be a vehicle would be
pulled over is there a way that the
officer would be able to test on the
roadside if that vehicle lamp is too
bright based on just opinion or is there
an
actual tool they
used there tool there there is a tool
however we don't carry it road side um
one of the other things that um can be
done and I know one of the in some
testimony I believe last week it talked
about a forced inspection if we stop
something roadside we can have it towed
in have a a an authorized inspection
station do a forced inspection uh to
address a certain area that I believe is
something that you could use in that
type of an instance or again doing some
follow-up information getting the
information on the light itself and
following up that way but there is a
method however roadside would be very
hard to do
that representative
Sykes thank you Mr
chairman um trooper I just want to make
clear in my own mind that um I'm not
exactly sure if it was last year the
year before we changed the uh red light
blue light law to reflect that fire
department could have a a blue light on
their ambulances and fire trucks I want
to confirm that this law does not it's
being authorized under one section of
the law I want to make sure it does not
impact that change for emergency
Personnel thank you for the question
that is correct U this this is this
particular bill is is addressing the
headlights yes um the the law was
changed a couple years ago uh to reflect
uh the NFPA standard for lighting on
emergency apparatus so this would not
affect
that I have a actually question for you
you mentioned in your testimony about
the headlamps that can change
colors is that relatively do does that
happen on newer Vehicles when I say
newer like newer model
vehicles so what I was referring to was
the actual Halo itself not the headlight
itself um there are some Led Halos that
will change color um I don't know how
it's Pro it's it's programmable because
the LEDs have a number of different
colors that can be emitted from them so
and I've seen them uh they change from
Orange to red to blue and everything
like that so um I can answer that
question okay so I did some research and
I uh posed several manufacturers that do
have the halo lights um and every
manufacturer that does have a Halo are
not programmed able and they're not
changeable they are only to be Amber
facing forward if they do change color
it's an aftermarket light and that's
what this is trying to prohibit the
aftermarket light is programmable with a
remote control you can do it at any time
while you're driving um I don't believe
that this bill is going to affect it if
the vehicle is parked sitting at a car
show or that type of thing but if you're
driving down the road or you're using
the vehicle Upon A Way
it's not to be changed it's supposed to
be one color it's supposed to be Amber
the manufacturer recommended color so I
guess that's my next question is can
these be
retrofitted to older cars yes yes they
do actually do make them for many makes
of vehicles older ones new ones all of
them you can
actually Amazon has has you just put in
Halo lights and a ton of them come up
they're all LED and
there those are the only ones that are
color changing the stock ones do not
change color I haven't seen them so I'm
going to keep my eye out when yeah
you'll see them purple pink all kinds
they actually move there's all kinds of
different colors over okay thank you
yeah any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you thank
you very much thank you and with that I
don't have any other cards uh for any
further testimony on this so I am going
to close this will close the the exec
session on HB 11 22 public hearing on
okay being 1106 I'm going open up the
public hearing on House Bill 11:23
relative to the registration of title
exempt Vehicles without disclosure of
personal information Beyond name and
address um we I held off for a few
minutes hoping the prime sponsor would
make it but whether it's weather or not
I'm not sure in the meantime as in
courtesy uh the chair recognizes
Bill thank you good
morning
this bill um reading my my sheet here is
going can I get you for the record state
your name
District I figured I'd cut right to the
chase you didn't let me off the hook you
off touche uh representative Charlie
stclair from District 5
lonia and this is House Bill 112 3
relative to the registration of title
exempt Vehicles without disclosure of
personal information Beyond name and
address this bill is going to eliminate
disclosure of personal information
Beyond names and address for the
vehicles thank you sir I'll take any
questions well sure any questions from
the
committee seeing none it's been a
pleasure thank you thank you uh I have
nobody else signed up for this uh nobody
from DMV or anybody interested in a
position on this no all right well in a
case like this folks um we can do our
due diligence um we we've got the uh the
bill in front of us um it does happen
from time to time that the prime sponsor
can't make it for whatever reason so
that being said I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill
11:23 and our next one scheduled for
11:20 is is
you
okay being 11:20 I'm going to open up
the public hearing on House Bill
11:27 relative to the revocation and
suspension of driver's
licenses chair recognizes the prime
Leon thank you Mr chairman and members
of the transportation committee for the
record my name is Erica Leon and I
represent the town of
dairy today I am here to introduce House
Bill 1127 which is a bill in two parts
um the first part of the bill deals with
the suspense the license the handling of
suspended licenses at the DMV and the
second part of the bill is to deal with
um a missing couple of words in some of
our statutes regarding driving a motor
vehicle with a suspended license I will
start first with um the DMV aspect of
this um so I am on Jael car the
administrative rules committee and we
were speaking about some of the
different um changes that were happening
at the DMV and how they were looking to
change how they handle suspended
licenses because um there's there's
quite a few reasons why they don't
actually want to hold on to them today
um this is something that the department
can speak to better than I can and they
are here today and um those are
basically around losing LIC losing the
licenses potentially in the storage at
the DMV having to mail it to people
having people not have what is our DEA
facto form of identification with their
driver's license or having to get a
non-driver's ID which is um yet another
step in another hurdle more recently
this has become a larger issue because
the DMV is part of state to state it is
a process that will flag a driver a
person as either a driver or a
non-driver based on what type of
identification they have and when you
this is to make sure that people don't
hold duplicate licenses and dupli in
multiple States so if you had a
non-driver's license because your
license had been suspended in New
Hampshire and you move to another state
they'll see the non- driver pointer and
they may not pull your driving record
you know you could be the worst driver
in the world with a record you know long
enough to drown this room in paper but
with a non-driver pointer your new state
may not know know that and may give you
a license so this is to close up those
loopholes uh the other is surrounding
driving a motor vehicle in the state not
upon a way after a suspended license um
so I made a huge terrible mistake after
session in 2022 I had a couple too many
drinks here in conquer and on my way
home I was arrested for a DUI there were
lots and lots of consequences that were
very appropriate to that but one
consequence of that was not appropriate
um in the statutes after a suspended
license you cannot operate a motor
vehicle anywhere in the state the way a
motor vehicle is described is anything
that is not under muscle power and is
not on stationary tracks that means my
husband had to do the errands take the
kids and then he'd have to come home and
mow the lawn because I was prohibited
from driving the riding lawn mower
because it is a motor vehicle I was also
prohibited from using the tractor for
the garden and all of these other issues
ises um I have done a deep dive nobody
has ever been convicted for this but I
wasn't that nobody has even been charged
with operating on their own private
property with a motor vehicle but was I
to make the gamble about spending seven
nights in jail just to take a little bit
more off in my husband's plate he said
I'll do the lawn I'll do all of this you
know I support you but he didn't do
anything wrong I
did and you look at my situation but
then you look at somebody whose job is
working for a landscaping company you
know they may not be driving the truck
but their job is to mow people's Lawns
you know the question about whether or
not their employer wants to keep them
after a DUI or another suspension is up
to the employer but if the employer
thinks that they are valuable member of
the team and they realize what they did
wrong and they're sober at work as they
should be on these lawnmowers do we want
to take away somebody's only method of
employment you know the consequences are
strong but we need to make sure that
there are not additional unnecessary
implications that follow that were never
intended in the process um of when
somebody is convicted of one of these
duwi so um this actually goes back to
how motor vehicles used to be described
in statute before we totally redid our
statutes a motor vehicle was described
as something that operates on a way um
we had our other driving rules but when
they were sort of standardized it was
left out to say that no person shall
drive a motor vehicle in this state
while the person driver's license or
privilege to drive is suspended or
revoked by the action of the director or
the justice of any Court in the state or
any competent out of state
jurisdiction um the second section which
is section four simply adds the words
upon away which standardizes that with
all of our other rules U surrounding
driving um the other part there is a
small little wiggle down in um section
five and six I don't know if any of you
guys have tried to find the boundary of
your property um um it is a nebulous
line that without a surveyor you don't
know where it is um and if you're mowing
your lawn somebody from the town who
doesn't like you happens to know where
that line is and you don't and you Veer
your lawn mower onto it that could get
your seven nights in jail again so um
this would just simply say that any
unimproved land between the boundary and
um between the boundary line of your
property and the roadside um would be
considered part of your property and not
the way just because if you have grass
that's going up to then a gravel
shoulder you know it's kind of crazy
that you have to know exactly where that
line is so um I hope that she'll be able
to um make things a little easier for
the Department of Motor Vehicles in the
license suspension process so that they
don't have to be surrendered and um also
just make it so that we don't have this
uh sort of Damocles hanging over
everybody's heads saying that nobody's
ever been prosecuted but do you want to
be the test case so with that I'm happy
to take any
questions
well thank you very much it does look
like you've done your homework my first
question is would you like to join us on
Transportation depends when you
meet represent St
Clair thank you um and thanks for coming
forward with this bill have you ever met
anybody in your entire life in this
state that knew that if you lost your
license for driving any influence that
would affect that you could not mow your
lawn on a motor IED lawnmower no I
haven't and I've actually had dozens if
not more lawmakers tell me that no you
it's proper property you can still
operate your lawnmower um but
unfortunately you know our job well our
opportunity today is to make our laws
actually say that thank
you any other questions from the
committee representative
sakes thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question um
I want
to I want to walk up walk away from the
lawnmower part of the bill to the the
part of the bill where it talks about
surrendering of a driver's license and
that seems to me as a much more
substantive um real world problem versus
nobody who's ever been convicted about
driving their lawm so could you just go
into a little could you please go into a
little more detail about how
that lack of surrending or um would
would work in the real world for people
uh thank you I can definitely go into
that um as you're aware many places you
go you're required to show ID whether
it's to buy beer or wine or liquor buy
your cigarettes um to go vote um to
enter certain private events where you
need to validate who you are um there's
our driver's license has become a de
facto identification card more than it
has become a permit to drive so with
this you need to also need to show your
driver's license when you're flying or
when you're traveling so um it becomes a
significant hardship when you don't have
an ID ID card to show and to provide um
one of the questions that had been
raised by somebody is well what if you
still have your license but your license
has been suspended will the police know
um I was talking to Senator Lang who um
who used to do be on the other side of
those stops with people and he said that
almost every single time you stop you
have a radio and you call it in you call
for a check on the person and the
validity of the of the license there may
be a couple times when your radio
doesn't work but you know there's also
the question too if maybe somebody gets
off that time when the when the radio
isn't working but do you want to
potentially end up in a confrontation
with somebody who's already knowingly
breaking broking the law when your radio
doesn't work I don't think that would be
a good idea you know there could be the
possibility of marking your license in
some way but then you're also it it
becomes more of a cost it becomes more
complicated I'm not sure that that's
necessary with the license um the other
part is around if you do surrender it
and then get a non-driver's license then
um then that works except it's another
trip in I know there's a lot of people
that are concerned about all of these
different costs that may be small to us
but may be the thing that ends up
meaning that a family Skips a meal
because they're spending an Uber to go
get to the DMV and then go spend $10 on
a non- driver's ID for some of us that's
not a big deal but for others it is um
but I really think that the largest most
glaring reason for this change is the
state's move into state to state because
having that system that can I make sure
that nobody has um a state issued ID
that it in multiple States and the fact
that you're flagged to either a driver
or a non-driver really opens up a big
potential Wormhole of unintended
consequences if we require people to
surrender those licenses so this has
been an established practice at the
department for a while it happened under
previous leadership and it's continued
under the current leadership to send
those licenses back um they they had
been operating because um the previous
the previous leadership within there had
already established it they didn't
recognize that there was a gap in our
laws that needed to be remedied so when
that came to the four at the Jael car
meeting they asked if anybody would help
volunteered any further questions from
the committee representative Coker thank
you Mr chairman and thank you
representative uh so you mentioned the
um um you uh you mentioned the penalty
for driving on a suspended license
that's seven days in or seven nights in
jail is that or ents the penalty for
driving under a license that's suspended
under a reckless or a DUI or any of
those more enhanced charges as they
should be is uh lengthens um time of
license suspension I forget if it's 6 or
91 months additional plus seven nights
in jail okay all right thank you you're
welcome representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman thank you for your testimony um
we uh over the summer there was a rumor
running around and I'm not sure if you
heard it of of um people being um
stopped for DUI but but some judge in
New Hampshire was suggesting to whoever
lost their license go pick up an
electric bike and uh and off you go um
it sounds to me from your testimony that
that would not be good
advice I would agree that that's
probably not good advice I've heard that
before and I knew a decade plus ago
somebody who had an electric bike
there's some part of the statutes that
may have some wiggle room there but this
part here um this part here that's being
addressed in um RSA
23664 would make it clear that even if
under another section of the statutes
you were okay to operate that electric
bike you can't under the statute and
this as this would change it still would
say that you can't operate that electric
bike upon a
way I look um does it also in um in that
statute does it also follow that you
wouldn't be able to use your battery
powered wheelchair or any other
device
um if you look at a strict
interpretation of a motor vehicle it is
battery powered it is on Wheels um and
actually it as you bring that up it may
be because the electric bikes if they're
just the one that has the extra motor
kick if you pedal and then have that
extra assist that may be one of those
gray areas between it about it not being
a moped but being something that's an
assisted Pedal Power um then if you get
into these powered wheelchairs it's kind
of discriminatory if you have somebody
you can sort of kick along able to use
their powered wheelchair after after a
suspension but somebody who can't sort
of kick along and and do a little bit of
Flintstones move it from time to time to
have some muscle involved um that would
just be absolutely discriminatory thank
you you raised great points we'll look
into that because actually the
wheelchairs are they have another
definition of personal Mobility device
so we'll look into that good point
anybody from the committee
representative sellers thank you Mr
chair so what about um getting back to
driver's license and IDs and stuff like
that what is what about um instead of
the driver's license being taken that uh
you have to voluntarily give it up in 10
days and get a non-driver's license
issued or if they do take one you know
then you have 10 days to go down and
swap it out to get a non-
driv um thank you so the way that that
currently operates with some of the
suspensions is they will take it at the
time and then give you a sheet that
allows you to drive for 30 days um if
you are looking at one of the ALS um
suspensions um I I looked into all these
different forms so with an ALS
suspension they take the license but
give you the pink sheet but with that
then it's returned the license is
returned to you in the mail with one
form that says here's your license and
another form that says you know if for
every day you hold it you're going to
have your license suspended longer so
this is part of a clean up and a true up
of the of the rules and then the laws
and the representative from the DMV will
be better able to speak to those
specifics for
you anybody representative
Jones Thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for being here
um I just wanted to
know why
LSA when legislative Services why they
didn't separate this is common sense
legislation I so thank you for bringing
it forward but why didn't they separate
the driver's license issue and the
boundary issue into two
bills uh well thank you both of these
are regarding suspended licenses and so
since they're both part of suspended
licenses they sort of work together and
then we have one hearing as opposed to
multiple hearings um it what it's just a
technical change um as far as the
procedures of the department in order to
make that change to the statutes to back
up the practice that they've been
undergoing and and um this other one as
well is is something that takes what
seems to be a common sense understanding
and puts it into
law I was just thinking that there could
be other issues that followup I'm sorry
I'm sorry Mr chairman yes follow up okay
I was just wonder there could be other
issues where the definition of the
boundary takes place other than
driving okay and uh would we be
upsetting a definition somewhere El else
in another piece of
legislation um thank you that is a very
good question if you look at section six
on page three um that's lines 30 through
33 in the definition of a way um it adds
a new subparagraph three that says for
the purposes of um RSA 26364 that's the
one driving with um with a suspended
license any unimproved land between the
boundary lines described in paragraph
one and the maintained portion of the
roadway um and that
has um if you go back to section one
which is in uh sorry sub paragraph one
which is just above that in section five
it has the definition of way there's
already a carve out for the paragraph
two so this simply would add another
carve out for that paragraph three that
only for the purposes of driving with a
suspended license would that change in
the definition of way take hold that
welcome
uh representative s yeah I just um you
may not be able to answer this for us
but um perhaps in your uh maybe you will
and I'm hopeful
um on line 32 of paragraph with
paragraph three I forget what page it is
um you talk about for the purposes of
the RSA get that any and this is where
I'm struggling a little bit unimproved
land what is that is it defined
elsewhere is it defined under the rsas
for motor vehicle operation is it a land
use zoning thing I mean I'm very
concerned about what that actually means
um thank you for the question if there
is a better term I would be happy to
change the term however when I asked at
OS um I asked various different bodies
what you would describe as sort of the
edge of the lawn the edge of whatever
land that you have that it doesn't have
a sidewalk on it it doesn't have parking
area on it it doesn't have any
improvements so if you look at even even
a drainage ditch is going to be an
improvement so as long as there are no
improvements to the land that take it
from its natural state Beyond just a
vegetative um issue that that that's
that's the intention of it if there's a
clearer way to say it I'd be open to
that because the clearer our laws are
the more people know if they actually
not yeah so my thank you for your answer
that's I think it it points to the
conundrum that we I think the committee
um I I wonder
how if you know I wonder do you have any
thoughts about who we might ask about
this because just by your statement
earlier does that not
include when you plant grass that's
improving the
land see that's that these are the kinds
of things that are buzzing around in my
head and I I I think we're going to need
to work on this and I'm I I love the
idea of the you should be able to take
your Almo and use it I have no problem
with that I but I don't want to
introduce ambiguities you know um thank
you I can talk to some people in the
planning department in my town and get
some advice as to who to speak to to see
um I I haven't seen planting a lawn as
improved
as much work as my husband puts into it
all the tilling and leveling and seating
and adding compost uh it's it's never
been considered an improvement when
looking for taxation or any sort of
use you're welcome yeah yeah couple of
good points raised and we will look for
some legal definitions uh any other
questions from the committee and so you
know I we do have somebody from the
Department of Motor Vehicles signed up
to speak as
well seeing none thank you very much if
I can say one more thing before I go if
you do want to clean up that a powered
wheelchair is not a motor vehicle I
would view that as a friendly Amendment
if that's something that you wanted to
include because I can't imagine that
being a standalone bill but I think it
could be
worthy we're going to look at that
because we also have to look at some of
the electric bicycles scooters and
everything else which is also
potentially being classified as personal
Mobility Vehicles by the federal
government so
thank you we we may reach out to you for
some help um and no other questions
thank you very much uh next up chair
recognize Jen for Bailey from Department
of Motor Vehicles in support of the
bill good morning chairman member of the
chair uh my name is Jenifer Bailey I am
with the Division of Motor Vehicles and
we are in support of this bill um we did
request the force first part of it for
surrendering of the license um so as
representative Lon discussed in
2022 New Hampshire went live with state
to state state to state is a program
that is rolling out Nationwide that
limits um a driver to one credential
therefore if you have another state so
you are a New Hampshire resident you
move to Massachusetts try to not
surrender your license to transfer
officially to them it will come through
and cancel your New Hampshire license so
you only have one valid credential no
matter which jurisdiction you are
residing in or hold a credential in um
so when we did that
we um eliminated the need to surrender
your driver's license when you're
suspended so not all violations require
you to surrender your license um the
ones that do are the ALS DWI Reckless
habitual offender and failure to file an
SR22 insurance policy any other if you
have a ticket that you're suspended for
you don't have to surrender your license
what this did was it put a restriction
on your record that until you turned in
or Surrender Ed your license you could
not reinstate whether your time was up
or not um this also required you to
either mail in drop off at a local DMV
office or bring into the conquered DMV
to turn that license in and get a non-
driver's ID under state to state an
active credential is considered one that
is active or suspended therefore if you
get a non driver's identification card
your license then gets cancelled so
you're suspended yes but now your actual
license is also cancelled so if you then
reinstate you have to go visit a DMV
office to have your license reissued to
you we do that in a duplicate process
but it was an added process that an
applicant then has to come in for so
when this happened we changed internally
our process that you no longer had to
surrender or get an ID and if we did
have them turned into them us we would
send a send back letter stating that you
may keep your license to use as
identification not for purposes of
driving um that has eliminated a cabinet
of thousands of licenses that we were
holding um it eliminates the risk of us
misplacing those licenses or mailing
them back incorrectly so we are in
support of this part of this bill and we
did request for this to maintain how
we're currently running our practices we
just are aware that the law did not
match what we were doing and we're
trying to make that now match um the
second part of the bill we um also see
no issues with I did provide some
written testimony and the upon away is
used in several other um driving offense
laws so RSA 2631
26582 265 A3 A4 and 14 are all laws that
you cannot be convicted of those vi
violations unless you are driving Upon A
Way in a motor vehicle so changing the
other law of operating after suspension
to also be upon away matches it to every
other violation law um that is all I
have I do have the RIS and testimony
with um more statements um but I'm open
for questions if you have any thank you
very much questions from the committee
representative St Clair thank you do you
notify other states that if they they
somebody shows an ID they're stopped
they're not driving but I want to see
everybody's ID in the car and they show
that ID and it's under suspension but
you've not required for that license to
be turned in now have you notified other
states that they don't need to be
grabbing these licenses yes we did go
through law enforcement and through um
other agencies that they no longer have
to surrender them right now the only
licenses that we do get surrendered to
us on a normal basis are ones um for
stock s with als's those ones are still
coming to us and we do mail those back
currently so I just a quick follow
clarify so you're telling me that all
other 49 states have been notified their
law enforcement not to pull a driver's
license from a New Hampshire residents
resident
because they don't need to well we don't
we actually have I've been with the DMV
for 18 years and we've never had a
license turned in from an out of state
law enforcement officer um so I'm not
sure that they're collecting them but we
did put out a memo um to Chiefs of
Police Association to not have to
surrender these any
longer and it wasn't necessarily law
enforcement that took them it was in
their letter to surrender them to the
DMV it wasn't law enforcement taking
them the only ones that law enforcement
took the license for was for ALS
purposes thank you any other questions
from the
committee represent foot thank you Mr
chair so when somebody goes to retrieve
their um license so you only mail it out
or can do they go in person and go to
conquer for example and retrieve it
personally or does it have to be mailed
no if the only location they can go to
have it physically handed to them is the
office representative a thank you uh
what happens if your license expires
while you're under suspension if your
license expires that would be one case
where you would have to opt to get a
non-driver in place because you cannot
renew um a license will it's under
suspension thank
you any other
questions representative sellers thank
you Mr chair so in that case you just
talked about there what happens when
their suspension is over what do they do
with that at that point do they what's
what's the process they would have to
come to a DMV location and have their
license reissued um or renewed if
they're expired
follow so is there additional cost as
well there is no additional cost besides
the renewal
price any other questions seeing none
thank you very much thank you uh with
nobody else signed up to speak on this
bill I'm going to close the public
hearing um not too bad we have a little
extra lunch um next hearing be at 1:00
you
all right good afternoon everybody being
104 excuse me I'm going to open up the
public hearing on House Bill
1158 relative to establishing an
exception to V vessel
registration chair recognizes the prime
welcome thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee um I uh introduced this
bill um uh based on information I
received from uh one of my constituents
or a cons constituents family uh are
here to uh maybe explain in better
detail than I can but basically to
correct what I perceive to be and I hope
the committee will agree is is sort of a
catch22 situation that exists under
current law the situation is this um
uh the one of my constituents uh Martin
moscowitz who will Who will testify next
um is 16 years old he lives in Windam uh
they live on cit's pond and he has a
small 12T boat that um has a i one or
two horsepower electric electric engine
um he uses the boat uh to uh basically
he he he takes he he uh buys ice cream
in one form or another and he takes it
out on the boat and he sells ice cream
to other people that may be out on boats
on the lake or whatever and donates a
sub substantial amount of of the
proceeds that he makes uh to charity it
seems to me that that's something that
we ought to encourage young people to do
as opposed to spending more time on
their cell phones or or uh uh being on
Facebook Etc the problem is this he had
the boat is registered it has tag
numbers it has the regular registration
but when he was out doing this he was in
he was pulled over by Marine Patrol and
said uh told that he's engaging in a
commercial activity and therefore he has
to have a commercial
license he was willing to get the
commercial license except that there's a
regulation of the Department of Safety
that says you can't have a commercial
license unless you're 18 um he's only 16
or at least was at the time um so I
proposed this amendment uh to exempt
situations similar to the one of Mr
mosit now I I should
emphasize that it's it's to the extent
that the committee believes that a boat
that is P that is a powered boat even if
the it's a very low power engine ought
to be registered I don't I'm not I'm not
suggesting that that shouldn't be the
case and I don't think he is either um
but but the problem here is he's been
told in effect he needs to have
two licenses if you will one for the
boat to be registered and one for him to
engage in commercial activity and he
would even I guess be willing to to get
the the commercial activity license if
he could but there but he's being told
no you can't do it because you're not
18 it seems to me that that's you know I
have some difficulty understanding what
what uh public protection interest is
Satisfied by this if the boat needs to
be registered great but he ought to be
able to do what he's doing I mean I
think this is something that the law
should encourage not not prohibit and so
that that's basically the uh the purpose
of this bill if I if you know if it
needs to be redrafted in some way um uh
to to to accomplish more precisely what
what the uh what my purpose is I'm more
than happy to do that to work with the
committee or any members of the
committee to try to do that but that's
basically what what um my intent is and
with that um I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you sir I see one
already representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um I ran into this with a uh a
child with a donut business um but we
ran into the Hawkers and peders side of
things as well um which I I'm seeing
nodding of heads behind you okay um but
this is basically a um
a floating lemonade stand is it
not and and did you look up um where we
stand in New Hampshire for for lemonade
stands and and the and the limits I
don't recall if there was a $5,000 limit
on things like that you know what I I I
do have I do recall having some
discussions about the lemonade isn't
isn't there something that limits the
lemonade stand to your property or
something like that if you're if you're
selling it on somebody else's property
it might be
I I don't know the details but I thought
that there might be something he knows
you actually hold on we'll call you up
in a minute okay um so anyway I you know
I guess all I'm saying is what I think
bottom line is there ought to be a way
for him to do this uh and right now he's
he's just Flatout prohibited from doing
it and it just seems to me that that
doesn't make a lot of sense I don't as I
said I I'll see what the why that's
further some kind of good public
policy representative C thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for taking my
question it looks to me like uh
regardless of whether or not the vessel
has a registration number on it he would
still be doing a commercial business so
I'm I'm thinking that what really needs
to be addressed is the age minimum age
for being able to to do commercial uh
business that might be a way sure that
might be a way to uh to to handle the
the the situation and again as I say I
think um what what we ought to change is
is is the basically what prohibits him
from doing it and if the way to do that
is to change the the age that might make
perfect sense to do
that representative SES thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
taking my question so I think
representative C has hit on um the the
points that I was curious about um one
is I'm concerned
about I'm concerned that I'm going to
phrase this a little bit that
um you've presented a very real world
problem which demands and deserves a
solution um but I I wonder why you chose
the route that uh of in terms of boat
res uh registrations because there's a
bunch of stuff uh
from federal regulations and the funds
that derive from boat registrations
there's a there's a question about how
algae is spread from pond to Pond and
they try to keep track of the boats that
are moving from one Pond to the next not
that that's here but um there's speed
enforcement issues it's there's a whole
bunch of stuff that it's a can of worms
that
that might be open and maybe the the
easier fixed do you have um so I was
curious about your point of view about
alternative Solutions versus the one
you've presented us sure sure no and
it's a good question you know one of the
things um that I drafted the bill this
way initially because I thought it was
sort of the simplest way but I
understand your point I and I think I
was not particularly focusing on what
you're what the concerns you're raising
which I think are legitimate
concerns the part of the difficulty is
that I think this the the whole sort of
270 statutory scheme is not all that
clear um you know for example it's if
you looked at just 270 e uh 2 and E4 um
that talks about the registration of of
of the vehicles it there's
no there's no sort of uh reference in
27022 at least inferentially talks about
having another sort of license the
commercial license U Beyond just having
uh the boat registered and so um that
was part I think part of the the
difficulty that I that I uh was was
dealing with and and as I say I was not
thinking of the particular issues that
you raised but I I think they are
legitimate legitimate
issues follow yeah thank you Mr chair
again um representative so now I'm going
to ask you
a a somewhat loaded question so you can
deal with it as you will um would you be
amenable to
having um amending the bill to fix the
problem which as I see it is that
somebody 16 can't get a Parkers and
peders license or whatever other kind of
license that he needs amending the bill
to fix that and then having it refer
re-referred to another committee because
I I I I have some you know I think
we're how do you feel about that yeah no
I mean that that might I I would be
particularly interested in how the
Moscow which is what they have to say
about that but I think that might make
some sense the only question that I
guess I would have is um
is
this is is is what Mr moscowitz is doing
is this really something that you want
to characterize as commercial activity
at all I mean without I you know it's
it's at a pretty low level um uh and I
and so I just I throw that out there
maybe you do maybe there are reasons
that you want to do that um uh and if
and if that's if that's the case then
you know I think it's perfectly it would
be perfectly legitimate to to simply
lower the age so that somebody like Mr
MTZ can is able to do it but I would
raised you know a broader question about
whether you really want to consider this
to be commercial activity at all um and
that's why you know I had put in the
limits of uh it can't involve alcoholic
beverages or uh things like that it
can't it has to be under a certain under
$5,000 a year that that kind of thing um
and and obviously those you know the
$5,000 is I I frankly just picked that
out as something I thought sounded
reasonable but if you know if it should
be higher or lower or whatever um
I defer to the committee on
that any other questions from the
committee the only one I have but I'm G
to I'll defer it to somebody else why do
I have a funny feeling there's some
federal regulations involved in this but
but uh I'll ask I think somebody else is
probably can nail the answer so thank
you
um I've
got both of the m moscowitz is here
would you like to come up together or
individually okay then the chair
recognizes Martin and Aaron muscats who
are in support of the
bill if I can get you to state your name
hi my name is Aaron mosz and uh this is
mosz um so to give you a little history
and I'd love to respond to some of the
questions that came up is the lemonade
stand log I did research it and it does
restrict you to your property and I
talked to the Marine Patrol the Marine
Patrol said well if he stands on our
dock on C's pond that's our property so
he can sell whatever he
wants but the minute he goes into the
lake now he's covered by state law and
State Commercial
restrictions so we did what we were
supposed to we did get the Hawker and
ped license while I think it should be
free for kids under 18 we do pay for it
we paid for it for three years now um
I'm a retired naval officer so I get
mine for
free but we have done all the research
we've done everything we're supposed to
do he has a 12- foot plastic
Coleman robo with a 0.1
horsepower electric trolling
motor it is registered as as the other
representative has talked about when I
talked to the Marine Patrol originally
three years ago he's been doing this for
three years uh we were told we had to
register the boat as a commercial vessel
as a ex-naval officer I'm like what are
we talking about here he said you have
to registered as commercial vessel you
were engaging in Commerce on a state
Lake I said
sure we register the boat as a
commercial vessel we've been doing that
for several years it has to be inspected
by Marine Patrol every year so the
Marine patrol officer comes to my house
saids where's the commercial vessel I
said it's right there on the
ground and he laughs at me he's like
what are you talking about like that's
the commercial vessel it's a 12 foot
plastic roboat he tells Martin that he
needs a life jacket level three PFD the
one that keeps your head up and put FL
we're like okay and he has to wear that
all the time well of
course we finally we got the Marine
control to agree on a ski
vest okay now we need a fire
extinguisher it's got a 12vt Col
battery Mar TR said okay we don't we
need a fire extinguisher oh we need a
noise maker we need a horn well we went
to Walmart bought a $5 air
horn he's got a light he's got
everything he needs safety wise to pass
Marine patrol
inspection we do that for three two
years last year the Marine patrol
officer came up sorry two years ago 2020
I guess summer
2022 came and said I don't want to do
this anymore I have better things to do
with my life than inspector 12 plastic
Robo registered as a personal vessel I
did I went up to conquered i d
registered it as a commercial vessel
re-registered as a personal vessel I
couldn't go to S Salem to do that had to
go to conquer to do
that and now it's a personal vessel this
summer my son gets pulled over by Marine
patol he has a sign up on his little
plastic rowboat with all the ice cream
that we get from Walmart and Shaws he
has his Hawker and pedler license
sitting there he has his reot
registration in a little plastic film
sitting there ready for the offer to
read he said you didn't register this
boat as a commercial vessel I'm like you
and at the same time the officer two
years ago Saidi can't register this boat
as a commercial vessel you can't have a
commercial driver's
license he will have a New Hampshire
State voting license at 16 when he turns
16 this
summer but he can't get a commercial
voting license so he's 18 there's a lot
of very con conflicting strange things
going on
here and all in all Martin
at 12 years old saw a Chronicle with me
there was a child who was doing this in
Lake
winaki and they did a 15minute thing on
this child who was doing this as a
teenager and is now putting himself
through college with a pontoon boat a
hot dog stand popcorn pulling up the
boats and doing this and the whole
article was
about um how he got his his food
license and now he's paying taxes
and Martin and I looked at each other
and said hey this is a great idea for
cob pond it's a service people love
it they get on Facebook and say where is
Martin going to be
today and the kids love it the renters
love it he goes up to the boats in the
middle of the lake they love it and the
Marine Patrol gives him
ultimatums last year when they pulled
him over and said well you don't have a
commercial boating license so you can
get out of your boat and sell ice cream
on anybody else's dock that's okay we
don't
care but you can't go to the middle of
the lake and sell ice cream to people on
a
boat and it's very
contradictory but I think the state
should be encouraging young
entrepreneurship Martin made well gross
receipts between $1,500 and $2,000 per
year he's donating between $4 and $500
per year year to pancreatic research and
memory of his
grandmother I think it's a great thing
for him it'll look great on his college
application and I I think the state
should support activities like this and
children like this who want to do
this thank you thank you did you want to
add anything or uh no I'm okay okay all
right um any questions from the
committee I think we've got your message
um any seeing no question questions I
thank you very much let's see what we
can do thank you uh next
up chair recognizes Tim dun Levy from
the New Hampshire Marine Patrol opposed
bill good morning Mr chair honorable
members of the transportation committee
my name is Tim Dunley I come before you
this morning representing the Department
of Safety Division of State Police
Marine Patrol unit uh and in the past
several years ago in my prior position I
know I personally had conversations uh
about this directly with the muset
family uh without getting into specifics
of every bit of testimony you've heard
uh this morning truly this is a
circumstance where New Hampshire
commercial boating law never considered
this type of
activity um and so I come before you
today saying I agree with representative
uh C incites that perhaps the
registration law is not the place to
address this as we do have Federal
requirements our federal exemptions I
mean our state exemptions for vessel
registration mirror that of the federal
law and the coast guard for which we
receive federal funds for participating
in to go beyond that to track these
registration issues the DMV you may hear
from them today um it's a software issue
exempting boats uh less than 15 feet uh
and then also
tracking the finances of an operation
like this while this may be one how many
others are there that might pop up um
and knowing how much they're going to
earn but they they've got to register in
May but the receipts don't come in until
September so there there are some issues
I respectfully suggest that you look at
RSA
27030 where there is an exemption or a
caveat in the commercial boating
operators
law where someone other under 18 years
of age can still operate a commercial
boat with
restrictions um and and uh 16 years of
age is still the magic number um but we
do allow 16 year olds to operate
commercial boats when they are in in the
case of a a camp sailing school
situation where they are for rescue
purposes only and if the wind dies and
they need to to sailboat
in our commercial law currently is
addressing things like fishing charters
the Mount
Washington uh floating
restaurants um Hotel tour boats where
those vessels are subject to the general
public boarding them not having any
experience in case of an emergency so
they those vessels and those operators
are held to a higher standard to protect
the public we recognize pedaling ice
cream is not endangering 80 people on
board so perhaps we look at
27030 and create something a little
different uh that might accommodate for
uh the situation you have before you
today I will say that um when when and
if you're entertaining that consider the
age three years ago Mr MTZ was young Mr
musz was 12 or 13 and and Marine Patrol
while the the the lemonade stand is on
the sidewalk you're now subject to the
traffic of maybe it's Kitz Pawn maybe
it's we's Bay on a
Saturday I'm not questioning his
decision making but we're opening up
that opportunity to have potentially a
12-year-old selling ice cream in in
areas where maybe it's not safe so all
things to consider I'm happy to work
with uh with you folks on perhaps a
solution and answer any questions you
may have thank you very much sir
question from the
committee well you'll probably be
hearing from a few of us but thank you
very much uh next up chair recognizes
Katherine and here Here We Go Again
Kathleen Dalman representing the
Department of Motor Vehicles not taking
a position on the bill yes thank you
chair and thank you members I'm just
here for informational purposes as um D
talked about our system right now it
isn't capable of tracking funds or
anything like that so we'd have to
reprogram our whole system which would
$25,000 all right thank you you're
welcome take any questions if there are
any sure are there any questions
representative
Hill um tracking what uh so right here
it said more than $5,000 of gross income
and if we' have to reprogram our whole
system because right now we don't track
anything like
that
followup y um so it wouldn't be as
simple as just having um any family
right in that they would that they are
doing this on the honor System that
there's under 5,000 you would need we
would need proof yeah
okay representative Fox thank you Mr
chairman so do you track commercial
sales other commercial sales we do not
we we track commercial boats how many
boats we have we don't track commercial
sale are there other commercial boats
that provide a
service such as this or similar or Food
Service I honestly would not not know
that
answer thank you you're welcome any
other
questions seeing done thank you very
much thank you um Mr duny can I can I
ask you one more question can I call you
back and that is yes sir an example of a
a similar situation and we where Lake
wiip basaki was mentioned that was UN
chronical and successful and able to do
it apparently is there a difference
between these two scenarios or did one
get enforced and one not no it's I'm
familiar with that operation as well
very familiar with it the registered
owner of the vessel is 18 years of age
and there was a second person on that
vessel the Young younger who was
actually in chronicle was doing the
selling as an employee or as as a family
member which is perfectly fine if Mr
moscowitz was out there with his son and
he's the registered owner and the
operator at 18 years of age we don't
have an
issue thank you very much I have nobody
else signed up to speak so I'm going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
1158 uh we'll chat about this later on
how to tackle it um before before our
exec session but uh whether it's maybe a
subcommittee on this one or we'll
see um just give us a few minutes to
regroup we'll be going right into house
bill
okay welcome to back everybody going
open up the public hearing on House Bill
1118 relative to the issuance of
driver's licenses for aliens temporarily
residing in New Hampshire the chair
recognizes the prime sponsor
welcome thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for hearing me today I am
Representative Steven Smith Sullivan
County District 3 Charlestown unity and
Newport in no particular
order so um this bill is a thing that
happens when somebody asks me to look at
a statute and I go oh my God no this is
a mess um it's a big reorganization
attempt so this applies to driver's
licenses for aliens temporarily residing
in New
Hampshire the first thing I noticed was
someone told me that not all of these
folks might have a Social Security
number but we had a statute with a whole
process for giving them a license
license the clean way to do that is to
put in a disclaimer or a car out there's
a lot of legal words for it the very
first thing you'll see that's bolded
notwithstanding RSA 26340 a 26340 a is a
standalone statute that requires anyone
to have a Social Security number in
order to get a New Hampshire driver's
license we might have been issuing these
to folks without driver's licenses
because this is in
26339 a but if we have been we ought not
be doing that because it violates the
other law because whenever we did that
um 263 39a it was sloppy without the
carve out so that disclaimer fixes
that moving down there is uh you'll see
some bolded type beginning in paragraph
two now what paragraph two used to be
was a
list all lowercase letters of
identification stuff documentation stuff
proof that you know how to drive a
vehicle or not and it was kind of
jumbled together to me those are two
different categories I'm trying to look
at it the average person to get an idea
of what do I actually have to do here is
very confusing
so all of the I know how to drive a car
stuff is in the Bold type at the top now
the certification from a foreign
government reporting regarding the
person's driving record and Licensing
status that was already there to it I
removed written or other testing proof
of vehicle operation in the foreign
country or proof of completion of an
approved driver ed education course
acceptable director struck those out
moved them up to the top and now you
need one of those in order to show that
you know how to drive a car at the
discretion of the
director B was already there that's why
it's not bold submission of social
security number or if the person does
not qualify for such number the
submission of certification to that
effect as is acceptable to the
commissioner so that's the one that
really wound my crank an explicit
provision in state law that says you can
do this without a social security number
without repealing modifying or
referencing 26340 a is bad legislating
and I probably participated in it so
there we
are uh the paragraph three there here
temporarily says so right in the title
so the director will Peg the term of the
license that they are issued with the
length of their residence in their haire
doesn't need to be valid after they go
home there is a drafting error that I
would ask the committee to look at and a
fix Roman numeral 2 says the director
may require any of the following uh that
means that the director is not required
to require any of the following and
that's again to me sloppy legislating if
we're going to give these list of
requirements well damn it is it the law
or is it not like did we mean it so
considering that uh lowercase a that
subparagraph is an option list you can
do any one of those things doesn't
matter up to the director and we
definitely want to know B if they've got
a social security number a good reason
not
to and they can prove that which in
commissioner paragraph one Roman numeral
one identifies the people the statute
applies to so down in
two
c we would like them to show that they
are one of those folks um we don't
specify the documentation requirements
or what they have to show they just have
to
say more than an attestation I am one of
these people here's what I have to show
proof of identification we need to know
who they
are whatever they can show the director
that's acceptable to DM DMV is fine but
these are the things that shall be
required so we want to know somehow that
they know how to drive a car that if
they don't have a Social Security number
they have a good reason that they are
one of the people this statute applies
to and that they are who they say they
are and uh most of this was existing
policy the biggest change would be the
ma to the Shell that we're absolutely
going to do one of these things to
determine that you know how to drive a
committee represenative Jones Thank you
Mr chair uh
representative I think what you did hear
is there's no really significant change
you just made it more user friendly is
what I'm reading
here um thank you uh I guess it's kind
of a major change
that in Roman numeral to we're now
actually going to say that these things
have to happen whereas before it said
May and we all know that when you put
May in a law it might happen might not
happen depends on who's around at the
time so I guess that could be considered
a major change except that I believe the
department has been doing these things
already so hopefully it doesn't affect
them makes sense thank
you representative SES thank you Mr
chairman representative Smith thank you
for taking my question um I just want to
be clear I if you can clarify for me
um you have um a requirement that they
proof of identification as may be
acceptable to the director might be the
question belongs for the director but
will that proof uh include their age
their
um whatever their temporary residence
within the state of New Hampshire is and
so on because typically when you get a
driver's license you have to prove how
who you are how old you are and where
you
live I like it but um I was trying to do
this with a light touch and not affect
what was there so I use the language
that was there um currently no it's not
required um I would imagine though that
any director would probably find that as
the subset of being
acceptable okay I didn't want to take oh
sure I I would love to have ripped this
up started with a blank page but I was
trying to First Do no harm sure thank
you for taking the question
representative C thank you Mr chairman
thank you Tak my question uh they're on
page one line 10 or
11 uh are you saying that it should be
read the director shall require any of
the
following yeah I don't know if you have
the same kind of copy I do Roman numeral
2 begins on
911 yes all right so what I'd like to
see is rather than the director may
require any of the following change it
to the director shall require the
following so the the proof that they
know how to drive that was all included
in subparagraph a as an or or or or to
facilitate doing that okay thank you any
further
questions repr Rumbo just be sure I
understand follow up on the prior
question thank you um that the way you
moved and if if it were to say the
director shall require the following
would be any of the options in
subsection a line 12 to 15 and then also
all the following b c d all those
sections correct yep correct so so in a
that's proven they know how to drive
whichever one of those is acceptable and
if they got another idea to add to it
I'm open to it but this is all the
language that was in the statute I just
moved it up but then yeah they um show
the social security number or why they
don't have one
prove that they're one of the folks
listed in paragraph one and identify
themselves somehow that's that's
it further
questions seeing that thank you thank
you next up chair
recognizes uh John morasco director of
the Department of Motor Vehicles in
vill
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee John morasco director of The
Division of Motor Vehicles and here with
me is the operations administrator uh
Kathy
O'Neal um thank you for allowing us to
testify here this afternoon so I handed
out written testimony um I will say that
I drafted that written testimony based
on the copy of the bill that I have
which is uh the copy um that is I just
had a supervisor at the DMV check the
website the same copy that's on the
website so that's what I'm working off
of I've had an opportunity to speak with
representative Smith and get a little
bit more clarification on aspects of the
bill I will say that I confirmed with
the Department of Safety commissioner's
office before I came here and before I
issued this written testimony to oppose
I have not had the opportunity to confer
with them again on the updates and
explanations that representative Smith
has offered um since I've been here at
the lob so with that um I'm going to go
off of the version that I have and that
we've reviewed as a team team um and I'm
just going to take it uh piece by piece
here um so the first section with
regards to um the social security number
um that is a practice where there's a
denial letter that is brought in those
those individuals that are referenced at
the beginning of the statute have legal
status in the United States they have a
legal right to come to the DMV and to go
through the testing and to receive a
driver's license if they pass and so
with that um if they don't have a Social
Security number um there is a denal
letter that they bring with them to say
that they're not eligible and I'll let
Kathy U O'Neal speak to that as if she
has anything to add so typically workers
or students f1s and such they they are
not eligible for a social security card
they will be issued a denial letter from
the actual Social Security
Administrative um they will come in with
that um so we can proceed with their
licensing
transaction so there's currently a
process to address um Social Security
numbers or lack thereof um that is a uh
both the documentation to be here um in
a legal status and have the opportunity
to come to the DMV and another Federal
agency through the Social Security
Administration on the denial letter to
say the person's not eligible for the
social security number um the second
part of the statute uh the May the
change from the director may require any
of the following to a shall um I think
there's there's some issues that I see
right off the top there and I understand
what representative Smith was trying to
do as he explained it to me he took
section c WR or other testing and bumped
it up um but right now if you look at
certification from the foreign
government regarding the person's
driving record and Licensing status I'm
being told by DMV supervisors we don't
ask for that today so if we change that
to a shell then okay that's one option
um in and amongst the others that are
listed here and at the end or written or
other testing um I could tell you right
now that everybody that comes to the DMV
that goes through the testing process
it's a very very good process and
everybody starts with that same Baseline
they don't pass the road test they come
back they don't pass the knowledge test
they come back they don't pass the
vision Acuity test they come back okay
so I say the written and other testing
option is what I'm going to exercise and
why because that's what uh RSA
2636 mandates um and it's also what the
DMV rule set mandates for non- us
transactions and any other transaction
for that matter so we're going to follow
the law we're going to go with the
written uh and the physical road test
that being said you could have a
director that sits before you years from
now that says you know what uh
everything here is an or uh I'm going to
skip the written or other testing even
though it conflicts with State Statute
and I'm going to say
that um I need you to bring in proof of
previous vehicle operation in the
country uh or proof of completion of an
approved driver education course
acceptable to the director well that's
unfair that's unfair right now somebody
from another country that comes into the
DMV that has legal status that's here on
a student visa or a work visa is able to
come into the DMV present that
documentation have it confirmed in the
save database and they're able to go
through the testing like everybody else
and get a driver's license if you have a
different director that sits before you
that says I'm going to lessen the
written testing portion and I'm going to
go with that well what if it's somebody
that hasn't driven and we just changed
the DMV rule set through jail car
because there's a section in there that
existed for many many years and that
section said if you came to the US from
another country and you came to New
Hampshire and you were over 18 you had
to take driver at even though if you're
a US citizen and you're a New Hampshire
resident and you're between 16 uh and 17
you take it and if you're over 18 you
don't have to you can come to the DMB
and go right to the testing process we
were having people in their 20s 30s and
older coming from other countries around
the world uh that were being held to a
different standard we changed that and
there's a bill that's coming forth
through Senator richardi to strike that
in the statute as well to mirror the
rule set um doing this would set us
backwards from where we are right now
we're trying to go forward and I think
that this law actually sets us backward
by mandating with a sha that one of
those things is acceptable it's a policy
decision by the director that's too much
power for the director to have we've got
a state statute we've got a rule set
we've got a program over there let
people satisfy the program
program I also want to talk about
reciprocity agreements you talk about
standards just because somebody comes to
the counter and they present a document
from another country I mean our
employees have a difficult enough job
preventing fraud conducting non- us
transactions making that making sure
that every document that comes into
their possession is authentic it's
incredible what they're able to do but
now we're going to go a step further and
say Here's the document um in that
document somehow has to be deconflict
with the country of origin to say not
only is it a legitimate document but now
what are we going to do go to the
website and figure out pick a country
around the world what are their driving
standards what does it take to get a
license there do you have to take a road
test do you have to take a Knowledge
Test how many questions are on it um
what's the caliber of travel in that
country is it a country that's more
focused on U bicycle travel moped travel
vehicle travel types of vehicles that we
drive here in the US I don't know but I
can tell you right now 400,000 customers
that come through our doors every year
DMV employees at the cter are not going
to be able to decipher that and figure
out um which country we can say yeah
you're good you don't have to take the
written test or the road test um you're
all set here you go here's a New
Hampshire license go stand there and
have your photo taken that makes no
sense the one part of the bill that I
look at that I say okay this this makes
sense because we're already doing it is
section
three talks about the term of the
license shall be no longer than 5 years
years from the date of issuance and the
director shall set a lesser term in
accordance with the length of the
person's residence in New Hampshire
we're already doing that it's Tethered
to the federal documentation their
length of stay is Tethered to the
license is that correct C correct yes um
so again it under undermines reciprocity
agreements you know we have reciprocity
agreements with France we have a
reciprocity agreement with Canada uh
we're working on uh painstakingly a
reciprocity agreement with Taiwan I can
tell you that uh DMVs around the country
have reciprocity agreements with other
countries why do they have that they
have that because they measured how they
test they've measured their standards
they're similar one country that we're
looking at is Jamaica Jamaica has a
higher standard a higher threshold they
get a license to New Hampshire it would
be very easy to enter into a reciprocity
agreement with Jamaica and feel good
about it but a lot of countries around
the world we just don't know what their
standards are and that's why you have
the reciprocity agreements and that's
what the mvs around the country do and
that's the right way to handle it the
way to handle it is not this and make it
a policy decision and put it in the
court of a DMV director to say forget
the written for you I want to see that
you've driven a car before overseas
that's not fair so we oppose the bill
questions thank you questions from the
committee represent Gorski thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question you mentioned earlier this
whole process starts you said with the
legal right to come to the DMV can you
explain a little bit more what you mean
by the legal right yes sir um and I'll
have uh supervisor O'Neal speak more to
it um because she's been doing it for
years I'm talking about visas I'm
talking about a work visa student visa
um something that has been vetted by the
US government that gives the person
legal right um to attend academic
institution or to work here in the state
of New Hampshire or in the US for that
matter and they uh that documentation is
on file with the federal government and
they bring it to the DMV which which
allows them uh the opportunity per uh
State Statute and what is on the DMB
website for what you need to bring in
for documentation to get a license but
I'll turn it over to C yep everybody
goes through a process they um have to
present documentation and then they get
approved by USCIS and they get either a
Visa a permanent resident card an EAD
card depending on what their stat uh
status is why they're coming here they
do get approval so when we do process
seed licenses we actually run their
alien number through this database it
tells us whether they're here illegally
or legally to actually be here to to
questions really I'm
surprised
um just in general terms going back to
the initial statement you said
describing legal I guess what I'm trying
to look at is because I've heard this
legal word thrown around a lot is legal
to be here
legally different than being here
lawfully
present what's the difference between
those two
categories I'll leave that to USCIS and
a constitutional attorney I don't I
don't have the answer to
that thank you anybody else seeing none
thank you very much thank you
sir I have nobody else signed up to
speak so I'm going to close the
executive session on I mean uh the
um we do have an executive session
scheduled for 2 o'clock uh I know both
there'll be caucusing for a few minutes
possible
all right good afternoon everybody sorry
for the
delay um I'm going to start off uh
we've got a few bills that I've opted
not to bring up today so I'll list those
off first in case you're here
specifically for it um if I don't take
it up today I will reschedule uh so we
1138 um I'm going to say 1304 as well
because it's a question on whether or
not everybody has a draft
Amendment and
1543 so if you're here to see the
executive session on any of those four
bills I will be rescheduling
them so that being said I'm going to
open up the executive session on House
Bill I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill
1031 and the chair recognizes
representative sers for a motion thank
you Mr chair Mr here I make a motion to
itl this
bill uh motion itl is there a second
seconded by representative Jones
representative sellers would you care to
speak to your motion yes uh I believe
this the 10 years is just way too short
even I have a pickup that's now 11 years
old and it's still worth 15 $20,000 and
I don't think a bank would actually give
a a note without having a title or I
guarantee the title's gonna the
vehicle's still going to be there so
thank you thank you sir any any other
comments or ideas from from the
committee seeing none I'll ask the clerk
SL Vice chair to call the role whenever
he's
ready and thank you very much
Representative gski no problem wait to
get my
invoice okay Vice chair votes yay
representative Smith
yes representative Hill
yes representative
Brown yes
representative
foot yes representative C yes
representative sers
yes representative sites yes
representative St Clair
yes representative
Fox yes representative Rambo yes
representative Vu yes representative
Coker yes representative Jones yes
representative
Walmer yes and representative tersi yes
yes three four five six seven eight
n 15 16
17 should be
that's
five one two three four five oh D's not
here Carol's not here and D's not here
so that's right 17
18 and Cilia rich but she's got
replacement oh oh
yeah I don't have that on my list we get
a replacement for Cecilia rich I got
Jeffrey
17 thank you thank you
17 to zero thank
you okay sorry for the confusion uh so
many different uh names on stuff
substitution list as well uh so the
committee recommendation of itl is
adopted 17 to0 and I did hear somebody
move consent so without any objection
consent it'll be okay uh that close
executive session
on 1031 give us a minute to
regroup
she did not give me pleas
confusing
okay
okay I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill
132 uh chair recognizes representative V
for motion thank you Mr chairman I move
OTP for HB
1032 okay lot to pass has been moved as
there second seconded by representative
Jones you care to speak your a motion
yes thank you um having a 20-year
floating time period for uh requiring
titles makes a little more sense than a
fixed period if you think about it in 20
30 40 years we're going to have vehicles
that still require titles even though
they're basically junk and worthless um
so going to a 20-year floating period
just makes more administrative sense
than what we do
now fair enough anybody
else really I guess everybody wants to
go home uh with nothing else no other
comments I'll ask the clerk to call the
role the motion on the floor is ought to
pass on
1032 okay Vice chairman Gorski votes
yes representative Smith
yes representative Hill yes
representative Brown yes representative
foot yes representative C yes
representative sers yes representative
Sykes yes representative St Clair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative Vu yes
representative Coker yes representative
Jones yes representative walner yes and
representative tersi yes and chairman
Walsh
yes 177 to Z I'm not going to catch us
this time 170 the committee
recommendation is adopt adopted um
consent been moved without objection
consent that'll
be okay fair enough we going to close
the exact session on House Bill
1032 and in a couple of minutes we'll
take
okay ready when you
are
I'm going to open up the executive
session on House
Bill
1447 relative to prohibiting certain
smoke emitting devices on Motor Vehicles
chair recognizes representative foot for
a motion thank you Mr chair I move to
itl House Bill 1447
FN to itl yep representative foot moves
itl is there a
second representative Jones uh did you
care to speak to your motion sir um
basically I think it's going to be
difficult to enforce this bill as uh as
it is and the expense associated with it
but not um so that's
committee yeah I'll leave it at that um
with nothing else un last the clerk to
call the role when he has a chance the
motion on the floor is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
1447 Vice chairman Gorski votes yes
representative Smith
yes representative Hill yes
representative Brown yes representative
foot yes representative C yes
representative sers yes representative
Sykes yes representative St Clair yes
representative Fox yes representative
restive rbo yes representative
veu yes representative Coker yes
representative Jones yes representative
walner yes representative torski yes and
chairman Walsh
zero okay the committee recommendation
of itl is adopted 170 do I hear a motion
for consent consent it is without
objection seeing none I'm going to close
the executive
session uh next up and give us a few
when open up the executive session on
House Bill 1391 FN allowing new vehicles
purchased in the model year or before to
be inspected in the second year after
purchase chair recognizes representative
CER for a
motion uh thank you Mr chairman I'd like
to move that
for House Bill 1391 for aop pass
second okay aop pass was moved seconded
by representative Hill do you care to
speak to motion h yes sir um so 1391 is
a common sense bill um we've looked at
it it uh the data doesn't support that
there'll be any kind of impact on safety
um you know this is something that we
could do small step in making a change
to our inspection program that uh that's
going to be measured and it's going to
save our constituents a lot of time and
um effort and I think it's uh what we
should do and it's from the feedback
from my community it's what my
constituents expect of me so thank
you anybody else from the committee
representative
SES thank you Mr
chairman um so I have a little bit to
say about this bill as well um I'm
opposed to the motion um I have a bunch
of reasons I'm going to try and keep
them as brief as I can um first and
foremost um the bill is unclear about
how
the not carrying out inspections on
vehicles that are less than that are
brand new or up to two years old and how
that will impact on uh EPA emissions
questions um now
admittedly folks will talk about how
this is a very small subset of the
numbers of vehicles that are um
inspected but I would caution us as a
committee to remember that
um when EPA standards are being
discussed the dep uh the Department of
Environmental Services could not be def
completely definitive about what might
happen if we were to change the
inspection requirements for for this
these vehicles how that would impact
their their relationships and the
working standards that they have with
the EPA in addition to that the
um one thing that's needs to be clear to
the committee as well is
that the percentage
of um greenhouse gases that come from
various sources in New Hampshire versus
other states is very different uh new
Hampshire has very
few um coal burning they do have one in
Bow they but they have very few power
plants which are a big source of
emission control which the APA does try
to control with scrubbers Etc um we also
have very few um other sources of
Industry that contribute to greenhouse
gases so I think the number is slightly
more than 50% of the greenhouse gases
produced in this country are coming from
motorized vehicles if we take out even a
small percentage of those
Vehicles where will the where and the
EPA requires us to make up the
difference where is that going to come
from and no one can answer that question
so that's one of my objections to the
bill secondly we heard testimony that uh
you know uh
and that uh as an example rental cars
their average use of rental cars is
which are primarily new vehicles um is
35,000 miles in a
year uh maybe I've got that wrong but
that's what I remember for two years
35,000 25 okay right I'll I'll take your
25 but I'll double it so because the
point is that
um there's no restriction on this in
this bill for the numbers of miles that
may occur now if you're like me and I
would suspect the majority of uh motor
vehicle operators in this
state you don't necessarily get under
the hood and inspect yourself as
carefully as you might otherwise and so
there's some there's a good chance that
you won't even notice that you have
problems with your vehicle that need to
be inspected even though it's within
that two
2-year possibility uh program cars um
you know people who commute long
distances to their job they're going to
be putting on significant miles and may
need to be
notified sooner rather than later which
leads to another problem
um most car warranties I understand it
are somewhere around 36 months 36,000
miles
nowadays okay so you go 40,000 Mi during
this time frame and they bring your car
in for inspection after the end of 2
years which is required now and the
garage says to you you have this problem
with your car it needs to be fixed for
it to pass
inspection who's going to pay rather
than being covered by warranty work
you're going to have to pay and I think
that's a disservice to our
constituents
um the primary Genesis are are or uh
impetus behind this bill was about
complaints about how the inspection
system
works and I will submit to you that the
Department of Motor Vehicles has made
some progress in terms of making vehicle
owners more aware that there is a a way
a road to figure this out no pun
intended
um by changing some of the things that
they do um I would also submit that um
beyond
that um there is no data I would repeat
again and we should be making databased
decisions not emotional decisions there
is no data to tell us the numbers of
complaints about garages supposedly or
not or supposedly I I'm being fair to
the majority of garage does there's no
data that says x a number amounts of
complaints were received versus X number
amounts of inspections were
conducted are we throwing the baby out
with the bath water
because of some loud complaints for the
a very small number of problem garages
where the majority of those garages are
doing their jobs as they
should um again no study's been
completed to make this connection I you
know I think that needs to be done or no
data was presented there's been no
actual studies
see the connection between vehicle
inspections and safety now the argument
is that there's only a this is only
affecting a small number of cars that
have motor vehicle crashes related to
some part of the inspection process that
failed I'll give you that but was any
data studied to see how serious those
crashes were and when is it when does it
become serious
enough that we should have done
something ahead of time and so there is
a connection in my mind at least until
we have real data that answers these
types of questions um so with all of
that in mind I would urge my colleagues
inpire of the feel-good nature of the
bill to vote against the motion so that
another motion could be
introduced anybody else from the
committee representative St
Clair thank you
uh as far as the air
emissions I think that our state uh
agency that is in charge of that has uh
has the capabilities to figure out how
the other plus 30 plus states that have
no inspections at all can see how
they're getting that uh enforced because
other states have many more cars than we
do in some cases close to a million
maybe more cars if you look at a state
like
Connecticut Pennsylvania Florida
Colorado uh what are they doing they
they have the same EPA regs that we do
uh so there's something being done and I
would hope that uh if this build is
advances that uh our local state agents
will uh will look into
that as far as a rental cars you notice
that you go to rent a car quite often
they have an out ofate plate there is no
restrictions to rental agencies to only
rent cars in this state with a New
Hampshire plate on it so you could have
a car with Pennsylvania plates on it
Colorado again Connecticut it
Florida they're not going to have a
sticker on it at any mileage or any time
so that's something to to think about
how we're how that's been not affecting
us per
se and I as far as people not looking
under the hoods again this is I'm just
answering my opinion on these um new
cars come with this thing it can be very
annoying it's called an engine
light so you don't even have have to
look under the hood because the thing is
going to start telling you engine check
oil check engine transmission low tires
pressure we have all these gadgets now
and for a lot of people that that is the
wakeup call is geez I better get this
checked out now granted they're going to
be some people that say I'm never going
to do it but they wer going to do it
anyway I think this is a logical
bill um and I hope that uh we vote to
pass it thank you
you anybody else from the committee
representative sellers thank you Mr
chair uh I agree with uh representative
St Clair and honestly I I think the bill
doesn't go far enough I think it's it's
great uh if you have the money to buy a
new car and you don't have to get a
sticker you save them 40 50 bucks but
I'd like to see this bill actually
expanded but we'll take it as it is
right now and on and looking at the um
the percentage of
EPA possible issues I mean if you we
don't I I couldn't find the number of
cars we sell in New Hampshire but I mean
if you if you say we're selling 20,000
cars a year and we have maybe 300 or 400
that had EPA problems that's that's
nothing it's a drop in the bucket you
know and as uh representative s Clair
said that especially on the rental cars
they come from all over you know
so we could have you know all these cars
from states that don't have inspections
and they're doing exactly what we're not
do able to do here and they at they're
brand new so I I I support this bill I
think it should
pass anybody else we Gorski thank you Mr
chairman um in my career I've I've had
the chance to buy a new vehicle and
recently bought a certified pre-owned
vehicle and I heard the testimony that
you know car can go over 70,000 mil in 2
years years and things can happen all I
know is when I brought my car in even
now they put it through a 17p point
check even if I'm doing an oil change
and they're checking to see if
anything's gone wrong and they're
checking to see to if there's anything
that needs to be repaired and I go there
because it's still under
warranty so the way I look at this is a
two-year car twoyear any new car is
still going to be under warranty and a
reasonable person is going to go back to
the dealer to do the basics and I've had
different types of cars and every make a
car has gone through a 17 to a 25 Point
check because of that it's gonna those
are the things are going to get caught
and from that because of that I'm going
to support this
else represent
Smith yeah on the warranty thing I think
one thing that we missed too was you can
do things that will void your warranty I
would never do that a warranty is a
wonderful thing because if I bought a
new car I would beat the well I would
beat something out of it in the first
year and make them fix
everything one of the ways you can not
have the benefit of a warranty anymore
though is not bring your car back in for
required Services if you're not
maintaining it properly through their
recommendations they will void your
warranty so I just Lo looked up chrys
service schedule they
recommend every 8,000 Mi or every 6
months to like 96,000 Mi I I don't know
if they still cover things there if
they're still covering things at 96,000
Mi maybe I'll go down but like 32,000 Mi
or 24 months um if you don't do this you
may have to replace your own engine or
whatever you break so these cars are not
going to be in disrepair in the first
year because people like their warranty
they paid way too much money for the new
car for the benefit of not having to fix
it
so really what's going to happen that
pesky check engine light comes on and I
have a new car I am going straight back
and I am not happy and I expect to get a
loner and I expect to get my car back
with the light out and everything fine
so I mean I believe there's zero risk to
increasing emissions through this thank
you anybody else representative Jones
everybody wants to get on this one thank
you Mr chairman um I'm just reading from
the position paper from the Department
of Safety uh in brand new cars last year
two 271 brand new vehicles were failing
their initial safety inspection that's
271 vehicles that probably the owner
didn't even know wouldn't have known it
needed maintaining unless they had that
inspection that's
271 could have been unsafe cars on our
road that could have been easily fixed
there would have been no burden on the
owner because it would have fallen under
the
warrantee and one other thing I just
want to pull from the Department of
Safety position um the goal the original
goal be reason for this issue was
complaints about the in uh the
inspection C stations and uh it says
here that complaints are thoroughly
investigated by troop by State Police
Troop G when violations are identified
through an audit or investigation harsh
penalties are
recommended so I think uh there's some
protections I'm I would be
opposed anybody
else I'll have to add a couple of words
myself um what's that I've been
defending the safety program for 12
years now and I always
will um and I've taken my lumps for
doing so I was originally going to rebut
some of the things I said but I'm not
going to because I think this build is
that easy um over the last few years
we've actually taken more of a turn at
trying to make the people hate it less
as a way to defend it for the future and
I look at this bill of being just that
uh I've had conversations with the
Department of Motor Vehicles and I thank
them for doing some of the things on the
receipts that you get from Gordon derby
with a phone number as almost a hotline
if you will to go after those shops uh
and these are all good things to make
people hate it less this is just doing
the same thing uh I think we can all
agree Common Sense uh with these
vehicles brand new what they cost and
under warranty uh I don't see a major
problem with unsafe vehicles on the
roads the other I did I will rebut one
argument for some of the things that
failed um a safety
inspection most of those things I don't
believe are covered warranty anyway um
there's not too many warranties for
atire
so again I I'll leave it at that um
let's again one more strive to make
people hate this less and maybe we won't
have so many bills to repeal it
completely in the
future thank you I encourage everybody
to vote for the autop
pass anybody
else seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the rooll when he's ready the
motion is ought to pass on 1391
okay Vice chairman Gorski votes yes
representative Smith
yes representative Hill
yes representative Brown
yes representative foot yes
representative C yes representative sers
yes representative Sykes
no representative St Clair yes
representative Fox no represent Rambo
yes representative veu yes
representative Koker yes representative
Jones
no Representative walner no
Representative tersi no and chairman
Walsh
yes 12 to
five yep 12 y five
n okay our committee recommendation of
to pass is adopted 12 to5 uh obviously
this will be going on the regular
calendar and two off to a second
committee as well so I'm going to close
the executive session on House Bill
1391 and just for our future planning
purposes
um I will reschedule these bills
uh they are early bills all these are
the early bills and so I we'll have to
do these the next time we come here
which will be on the 30th uh I I think
we can afford to take off the week of
the 23rd we meet on Tuesdays that's
election day so I think we're in pretty
good shape to take the week off uh so
30th is our next time here I will do the
same thing public hearings in the
morning in probably a pretty lengthy
executive session in the afternoon just
to get caught up so unless there's any
yes yes oh um are you are you going to
do a Minority Report yeah me a okay and
anybody else with u uh reports if you
can get them to me before you leave
you